we're one of the richest countries in
the world
and we've got a need for people to come
and get free food because
they can't afford to buy it
people who were working after they've
paid the bills
they've got nothing that's all they do
without
right
i came here about two weeks ago to
deliver some food to somebody
and then somebody else come down and
said can i have some she said i've run
out of money and i've got no food left
and i thought to myself have we on
something here
if you know anybody that needs anything
we're going to be here for a while
until then i'll send him neighbor a lot
of people on there who appreciate this
yeah yeah give them food trying to do it
we're going to do it every week now yeah
a lot of people need it a lot of people
find it tight
on benefits i find it hard
it's been bad me i've been there
struggling
i lost my job in in the first lockdown
and so i'm on universal credit and it's
really hard
i've worked most of my life so to be on
universal credit you've barely got any
money
so yeah it's just you're in the same
boat yeah yeah she's got kids
i've got kids as well so it's tough just
gotta take you stays it comes really
aren't you
i worked in offices all my life i'm
looking at working in tesco i forgot
yeah we'll walk apply for tesla yeah i
think yeah
anything we can get right now isn't it
yeah
[Music]
the first time i went to a food bank i
was really embarrassed i had my head
down in shame but then i realised
there's
so many people out there in the same
position
[Music]
we shouldn't have food poverty but we've
got it and
people like these need it people who are
working
after they've paid the bills they've got
nothing
people shouldn't be in this situation
i'm sorry if i can't um
yeah people should be in this situation
in this
something
oldham in greater manchester home to a
hundred thousand people
towns like oldham struggled long before
the pandemic arrived
when industry fell away it became one of
the most deprived
towns in england people's health
declined
jobs became scarce but what's become
clear as a year into this crisis
for an awful lot of people those issues
have got much
much worse here you go here is your food
pack
this stuff is just um out of date but
it's still okay it's best before so we
do want to take
some shredded wheat do you feel free
the local library on the fitton hill
estate
hasn't loaned a single book for a year
now
today it's a crisis center run by a
charity called
real over here we have an older lady
that's told me that she's struggling
with the heating so making sure that
she's got enough
blankets and warm clothes and these are
for two boys and a girl their family are
just struggling with money anything to
buy them
toys or clothes we're just making sure
they've got what they need at the moment
this service is in huge demand now
because poverty levels are so high here
yes no worries
one in three children are living in
poverty in oldham
more than anywhere else in the uk this
is mackenzie
he's just turned 13. this is kobe he's
four
and this is freddy and he's free jessica
is an
absolute amazing person but yeah just
doesn't
um have enough money to get by
i've got your food there i've put some
shampoo and stuff and some
um children for mackenzie how are you
having a bad week this week but i think
that was me as well because i've not
been sleeping
and things just going on in my mind
i rang school and asked to move the
chord helped me with a laptop because
mackenzie
only were doing work with paper but
they've put him on a list and he's still
like not even halfway up the list
we put a bit of a shout out to see if
anybody had a laptop that we could use
for
the mckenzie i did contact the school
myself to see if it was something we
could get and yeah for whatever reason
he
he wasn't able to access that but yeah
now he's got it
being stuck at home is expensive for
families like jessica's
last year the government raised
universal credit payments
by 20 pounds a week but that extra money
is due to stop
in april some nights i'm normally in bed
for seven o'clock
just go to bed with the kids why
um i just don't like sitting downstairs
on my own
like it's just sometimes i just sit
there my mind ticks over and constantly
takes over
like thinking about things and like
um like if i get paid i know if i'm
going to be able to do the next shopping
or
if the kids need summer and i've not got
it how am i going to get it and it's
just
things just go through my mind
[Music]
hi michelle come in please take a seat
how are you today when i qualified as a
gp and i just thought i will just come
and sit and prescribe medication
and that's all my job is
as well as being a gp zaheed shahan
is also a local labor councillor i
remember first time seeing a patient who
was losing weight and
and i said so have you thought about it
by you losing weight
essentially because i could not get
anywhere and his response was
i have not got money to eat haven't
eaten for three days i couldn't believe
myself and i thought
that can't be true that can't be really
true and over the years i've seen that
increasingly more and more and more
and in a way kovit has exposed all those
inequalities
what we're seeing today is manifestation
of that crisis
which has been building up over over the
decades
[Music]
this is our food bank and they can take
as much as they want and there's lots of
volunteers here
you know it's buzzing on saturday that
we have it
the other day like a man came in here
and you could tell it was lost
he's thinking what have i got to do in
here
what do they want from me he was a bit
suspicious you know what i mean we were
saying to him
come on come on sit down don't worry you
know and he's thinking what am i gonna
sign for this you know what
so we try to make them at ease and say
listen
don't worry we are for you
yeah and you're the only person that
matches here
and we're gonna cater for you so just
chill out relax
and we're not going to leave you alone
until we you've sorted you out
this epidemic is brought everything to
the fore
that might be true but many here are
suffering in silence
more than five thousand households in
oldham are living in overcrowded
conditions
a fifth are ethnic minority
multi-generational households
living their lockdown out of sight
[Music]
in this house there's four of my
brothers including me
two of my sisters and then my
sister-in-law and then
my niece and then my mom and dad
and that's it four generations of the
same family live in this small
terraced house the family business
collapsed in the pandemic
because of the lockdown the business has
gone downhill it's
more hard for us to make money there's a
nine-year-old boy here
and he tells me with a beaming smile
that his favorite subject
is maths but he hasn't been to school
since march
and he's done hardly any work at home
all we do is stay home locked up
proper hard
they're not learning much because our
home is not the right environment for
them
so it's much harder for them to learn
and they're losing out on a lot of
information do you think people realize
how hard it is for
families like yours nope no one realizes
hello hello nice to see you nice to see
you how are you i'm very well thank you
thanks for letting us come and see what
you do now it's my pleasure
a decade ago father tom davis started
handing out food from the vicarage door
it earned him the nickname the pot
noodle priest
for me this has become my church i spend
more time
in here than i do in my own church jesus
took
bread and fish i taped baked beans and
pasta
for 2020 we've had just over 17 000
people
17 000 people and in a normal year
what what would that have been 2018 2019
might have been 8 000
more than so we've doubled is this an
example of
the welfare state failing
i think it's probably more like the the
welfare state overloaded
my fear is what's going to happen when
furloughing is over
because in a way that will be another
crisis
i've been coming to food banks for well
over a decade now and this is the first
time i've seen one
on such a big scale you know they used
to be all about
tins of baked beans and a few grams of
pasta
but now these are huge it's the
evolution of food banks
and what this shows is that as demand
grows
the food banks have to grow with it
[Music]
in a few weeks time the chancellor will
reveal the government's plan
to recover from colvid but britain is
already in the worst recession for 300
years
and that recovery will cost money
the north we're tough and we're gritty
and we try our best to
work together and and support one
another but we do need
we need we need the correct investment
and not to be forgotten about
i do believe that towns like oldham
will be left with a long economical
impact of kovid as well which will
further exacerbate
inequalities in our society
i think in some ways
the government is still struggling to
cope with the situation that we're in
and that's what they need to invest in
so that we can support people who are
not work ready yet
to get them where they need to be
[Music]
the house is like a prison like you're
just stuck in it constantly
the kids have really struggled quite
really bad especially corbin
he's really out of your routine aren't
you
yeah you know not going to school seeing
his friends
sorry
kids love being outside so we just go
off along bars like the other day we
went on a three-hour walk
like we just went to park bridge and we
just walked and what and they absolutely
loved it
lovely to see you and i'll see you next
week yeah have a good week yeah
stay safe see you later bye
it's just not good you know being on
your own like
kim's always at the other side of the
phone but like if it didn't have it then
i probably
i probably would have lost it by now and
the kids have kept me going but they
they're really struggling at the minute
but yeah
i've even had to ring the doctors to up
my depression because i've not been
sleeping
do you feel like you're on your own
sometimes
yeah this week i felt so lonely in my
life
you